what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to a
brand new nba young boy
song called there you go dada
okay oh i guess it's k3 and casey i
don't even know
um before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos
so for those of you that are new to the
channel i don't really listen to rap
music outside of this channel so this is
just going to be me
interpreting like what the song is
[Music]
is
oh my gosh that's the cutest thing i've
ever heard
he's got his stuff oh my gosh that is so
cute
is this literally just gonna be his son
like half talking the whole time
[Applause]
oh my god i have no idea what he just
said let me listen to that again
concentrate right now
okay so he said he was gonna concentrate
but he's high so i would imagine that's
like counterproductive
and i think he's like speed racing maybe
down the highway
each way at home cause i don't know
[Applause]
okay so he was saying that he really
likes frosted flakes
which i think is a very acceptable form
of cereal
like i would rank that in my top five
cereals
honestly um and then he talks about
being high
and then his kid comes back on the track
which
i don't know his kid is cute i think
that's the picture
[Music]
half of that whole song was just him
like
his kid like half rapping oh my god i
could do that
the the first half anyway um on a scale
of one to five
i'm gonna have to give this song like a
two i hate to say it but
his kid just really isn't that good of a
rapper um i know he's three
but you know i'm reviewing the song
i think it's a cool idea but like if i'm
being honest
the kid just wasn't that good he was
okay and then nba young boy raps for
like
30 seconds then it goes back to the kid
so i'm gonna give it
a two on a scale of two one to five the
themes in the song i think he talked
about being high
and then he was telling his son how to
say words that's like the two
and there was a drag race so those are
the three the three
themes that i saw from the song but let
me know in the comments if i missed
anything you guys are always very good
at keeping me up to date
do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and ring that notification
bell and i will talk to you guys next
time